c'est l'heure de notre seconde débat
pour le dernier thème de cette deuxième
saison de sens public on va partir en
vacances il y a avec vous en se posant
la question du
surtoutisme certains sites saturent et
on choisit d'instaurer des quotas
d'autres commencent par des mesures on
va dire un peu moins drastique exemple à
Étretat plus d'un million 500000
visiteurs l'an dernier reportage signé
Marion vivre
c'est un site majestueux la plage
d'Etretat c'est falaises de Crêts
blanches qui dominent la Manche et son
arche de pierre des paysages mythiques
de la Haute-Normandie tellement mythique
que l'année dernière encore 1,5 millions
de visiteurs les ont arpentés en cause
le boom du tourisme local post covid le
succès de la série Arsène Lupin ou
encore les milliers de publications sur
les réseaux sociaux une aubaine pour
l'économie locale un désastre pour
l'environnement déjà fragilisé par le
recul du trait de côte Chaima la est une
enfant du pays elle vit à Étretat et se
bat aujourd'hui contre ce phénomène du
surtourisme qui a ses yeux endommage le
milieu naturel une des conséquences du
sur tourisme c'est la disparition des
galets
les galets ils sont là pour pour
protéger notre village de la submersion
des innovations des tempêtes les gens
ont tendance à prendre ces galettes pour
juste le les exposer chez eux ou parfois
même les revendre alors que c'est
interdit les revendes sur Internet les
jours plein la fréquentation peut
atteindre les 10000 visiteurs alors pour
préserver le site quelques aménagements
ont eu lieu fini le parking en haut des
falaises il faut monter à pied et suivre
un sentier unique pour sécuriser les
lieux et éviter les piétinements
incessants qui ont fait disparaître
l'herbe mais pour les associations
locales il faut aller plus loin d'un
point de vue de préservation de
l'environnement et c'est pas suffisant
les âges il faudrait instaurer une jauge
de fréquentation peut-être par exemple
on pourrait considérer qu'au-delà de
5000 personnes le village ne serait plus
accessible si on le préserve pas
maintenant je pense qu'il y aura une
interdiction à l'avenir si la falaise
disparaît parce qu'on la trop on la trop
piétiné mais là personne pourra en
profiter et ça ce serait vraiment
dommage autre problématique ce village
de 1200 habitants n'est pas adapté à une
telle fréquentation pas assez de
commerce pas assez de parking et une
ville locale qui se dégrade pour les
habitants
Marie Océane et son mari gèrent l'école
de voile de la commune arrivé il y a
deux ans ils ont eu beaucoup de mal à
trouver une maison à acheter tous les
biens qui étaient dans notre dans notre
type de recherche
partez extrêmement rapidement et
notamment on a eu plusieurs fois le cas
où on avait des rendez-vous pour des
visites et où le bien était acheté par
téléphone le jour même donc on avait
même pas la possibilité de le visiter
étant donné que il partait et c'était
systématiquement pour de l'investisseur
qui venait pour en faire du Airbnb mais
pour les élus locaux pas question de
mettre être tasses ou cloche eux veulent
miser sur une meilleure répartition des
touristes sur l'ensemble de l'année et
surtout le territoire de la Côte
d'Albâtre que les locaux évitent
certains weekends qui sont extrêmement
surchargés vont faire des parkings en
déconcentré des parkings un peu plus
loin c'est le cas de
Saint-Guilhem-le-Désert c'est le cas du
Mont-Saint-Michel soyez bien qu'ici on
peut pas fermer le village Étretat les
entrées sont multiples donc il faut ça
passe par de la pédagogie tous les ans
on a un camion site info qui tourne sur
des communes qui vient donner des bonnes
pratiques depuis cette année être ta
fait partie du label grand site qui doit
garantir un tourisme de qualité et ce
alors que dans le même temps le site de
voyage américain phodor a placé les
falaises sur la liste des 10
destinations mondiales à mettre sur
pause car victime du tourisme de masse
comment réguler ses afflux de touristes
préserver les sites naturels restez la
première destination mondiale c'est le
défi français dont on débat avec Sophie
Lacourbe bonsoir bien sûr vous êtes
directrice générale d'Advance tourisme
Florent maillet bonsoir bienvenue
journaliste au Figaro Valérie bonnet
bonsoir cette secrétaire général des
entreprises de voyage avec nous en
duplex également Richard kitef qui est
le maire de Gordes magnifiques villages
de Gordes dans le Vaucluse bonsoir et
bienvenue et Laetitia cruppa évidemment
est resté à mes côtés je commence par un
chiffre ce constat 80% de l'activité
touristique se concentre sur 20% du
territoire français voilà on est dans
dans cette démonstration de ce qu'on
appelle le tourisme de masse ou le
sourtourisme d'ailleurs on verra s'il y
a une différence
quels sont les sites les plus menacés
c'est les cités évidents c'est-à-dire
que voilà c'est en fait c'est tout ce
que les gens connaissent en fait ils ont
envie d'y aller parce qu'ils sont très
connus donc ça va à Paris la Tour Eiffel
ou le Louvre qui vraiment Versailles
extrêmement sur fréquentés et puis voilà
Étretat alors par contre c'est les
raisons qui sont différentes parce qu'on
va être temps alors qu'on y allait moins
avant mais on y va parce qu'il y a une
série télé alors que on va au Mont
Saint-Michel voilà sur Arsène alors
qu'on va vraiment Saint-Michel depuis
très très longtemps pour d'autres
raisons donc il y a aussi des raisons
différentes parce qu'il y a eu aussi une
série télé sur Netflix qui amène le
monde entier Émilie et oui absolument
oui ça ça les touristes c'est vraiment
cools féminins comme ça est-ce que c'est
forcément nouveau ce qu'on appelle le
sur tourisme Florent maillet c'est pas
forcément nouveau c'est la manière
peut-être de le qualifier qui est
nouvelle alors surtout risque le terme
même fait pas l'unanimité c'est
effectivement un terme qui est très
employé dans la presse parfois raccourci
les professionnels en général préfèrent
parler de pic de tourisme qui correspond
peut-être d'ailleurs plus à la réalité
je pense notamment à l'exemple qu'on a
en tête relativement récent du
Mont-Saint-Michel ou effectivement
pendant un week-end c'était le weekend
de l'ascension de mémoire il y a une
journée qui était la journée du vendredi
ou effectivement on a vu des photos qui
ont défilé sur les réseaux sociaux je
veux pas dire de bêtises il me semble
qu'il y avait 25000 qui est 25000 je
crois visiteurs dans la journée à un
moment précis c'était pas le cas le
samedi c'était pas le cas le dimanche
donc c'est pic de tourisme sur touriste
c'est pas forcément un phénomène nouveau
ce qui est nouveau c'est qu'il prend
davantage d'ampleur et que les
populations s'en emparent alors ça c'est
le chiffre que vous donnez effectivement
c'est à un moment précis ce qui est déjà
assez vertigineux mais il y a cette
autre chiffre sur sur une journée
complète à ce moment-là on arrive à
36000 visiteurs au Mont-Saint-Michel
c'était là pendant l'été
2022 Valérie Benade est-ce que la France
est perçue comme un pays de surtourisme
et est-ce que vous employez ce terme
tiens alors sur le terme je dirais qu'on
est plus
sur des plantations de la surfé ou de
j'ai envie de dire de la congestion
endroit de lieu à un moment donné et
dans et donc sur un territoire
effectivement j'ai envie de dire quand
on parle des sites qui pourraient venir
à l'esprit les sites classés au
patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO voilà en
France clairement on est dans quelque
chose qui est vraiment très fréquenté
voire problématique quand même sur
fréquenté à des moments dans l'année et
pour répondre à votre question est-ce
qu'on est perçu comme une destination
typiquement sur fréquentée moi je n'ai
pas l'impression que la France en tant
que telle disait au départ il y a même
20% de personnes sur enfin le maximum
sur 20% du territoire il y a des lieux
des lieux
des lieux patrimoniaux des lieux
simplement
géographiquement parlant le littoral etc
et dans sur le littoral des endroits
particuliers à des moments de l'année et
j'ai envie de dire même des quartiers
dans des endroits si on pense aussi à
Venise ou ailleurs voilà on peut très
bien faire un pas de côté et trouver des
choses mais c'est compliqué quand même
de demander un asiatique un Américain
qui n'est jamais venu en France de ne
pas venir voir la Tour Eiffel Versailles
lors de sa première visiteur c'est autre
chose les prix les prix les
primo-accédants parce que il y a
effectivement dont on va on va essayer
ensemble de d'esquisser les stratégies
pour limiter les effets de ce de ce
tourisme de masse ou de ces pics de
fréquentation il y a cette théorie du
pas de côté
il y a des choses très belles à 10 km à
l'est ou à 20 km au nord sauf que les
primo
ou primo voyageur
d'empêcher quelqu'un ce que ce que tu
disais tout à fait juste voir la Tour
Eiffel c'est impossible quelqu'un qui
vient pour la la première fois qui a
fait des milliers de kilomètres et
peut-être c'est sa seule fois où il va
venir en France c'est impossible de
m'empêcher ce que ça veut dire que ça
peut rentrer dans les critères de
sélection de ceux qui auront le droit de
visiter la Tour Eiffel pro
projetons-nous un peu un peu plus loin
dans le temps Florent myssa est-ce que
oui ou non vous êtes déjà venu avec la
data ça doit être possible de faire ça
alors pas de côté parfois il va falloir
chausser les bottes de Seat lui parce
que pour trouver des alternatives à côté
ça existe tout simplement pas je pense
qu'il y a une petite différence quand
même si on prend la Tour Eiffel ou
Disneyland Paris pour prendre un défi
bien sûr les plus visités et les sites
naturels la différence c'est quand même
que ces sites comme la Tour Eiffel
d'abord en général c'est des sites
payants donc quelque part vous avez une
action vous avez un moyen de de
contrôler de monitorer d'anticiper donc
je pense que la problématique est pas
tout à fait tout à fait la même la Tour
Eiffel ça reste du domaine du fantasme
un fantasme qui entretenu par les séries
on l'a dit mais aussi par la France
enfin par les Français eux-mêmes les
premiers visiteurs de la France c'est
d'abord les Français faut pas l'oublier
donc oui une fois dans sa vie on a envie
d'aller à la Tour Eiffel la seule
différence et là je pense que ça pose
pas de problématique fondamentales c'est
qu'on va l'organiser peut-être
différemment alors Richard Guitton on va
commencer une première fois à se
concentrer sur l'exemple de de Gordes
qui a été classé plus beau village du
monde par un magazine de voyage
américain est-ce que vous avez ressenti
une sorte de d'effet d'accélérateur un
avant et un après
on peut estimer qu'il y a eu une légère
accélération d'environ 20% des chiffres
de fréquentation mais ce sont des
estimations à ce stade et on peut dire
que globalement on est quand même sur un
pic de fréquentation grosso modo
équivalent à celui des années
précédentes hors covid et hors
confinement évidemment ça veut dire
combien de visiteurs par an à Gordes
on estime à environ un million de
visiteurs par an à Gordes au sens où la
commune et c'est pas du tout la même
chose que le Mont-Saint-Michel est très
grand dans superficie au
Mont-Saint-Michel vous avez un kilomètre
carré qui donc centralise en fait
l'impact touristique principal agorde on
a 50 km² de territoires de masse de
pierre sèche d'architecture provençale
typique donc le tourisme est plus dilué
nous on n'est pas vraiment dans ce
phénomène du tourisme de masse que vous
décrivez et qui est un phénomène
extrêmement préoccupant c'est un enfant
de la mondialisation en quelque sorte
nous on est plutôt dans des pics
effectivement de fréquentation
touristiques en juillet et août des pics
de fréquentation qui sont interpellant
mais qui actuellement sont sous contrôle
alors je parlais d'équation compliquée
difficile à résoudre il y a d'autres
chiffres selon l'Organisation mondiale
du tourisme 95% des touristes mondiaux
visiteraient moins de 5% des terres
émergées on est à peu près dans les
mêmes dans les mêmes rapports que ce que
je donnais tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'il y a une prise de conscience
c'est-à-dire que même dans ces sites qui
ont fait basculer leur économie année
après année décennies après année
décennies vers le tourisme elles sont
quasiment exclusivement tournées vers le
tourisme est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'elle
rétropédale un petit peu oui
nécessairement puisque c'est aussi
l'économie du territoire et c'est comme
vous le dites très justement
principalement l'économie du territoire
et touristique pour beaucoup de
territoire donc oui il y a une vraie
prise de conscience parce que
l'écosystème est abîmé en fait et quand
c'est abîmé les touristes viennent pas
donc c'est complètement logique que les
les destinations prennent en main ce
genre de choses Venise Amsterdam enfin
tout le monde enfin pas tout le monde
mais beaucoup de ses destinations qui
sont très fréquentées à des moments
particuliers de l'année effectivement
prennent en main ce problème parce que
c'est aussi le problème des habitants
parce qu'il faut pas un lieu touristique
il y a des gens qui ont une activité
professionnelle au milieu des touristes
et des gens qui me font rien donc ça
c'est leur environnement qui
souvent l'un des plus belles
environnement
au monde puisque ça attire tant de
tourisme dégrader et ça il y a une vraie
prise de conscience alors je sais que
les professionnels on a du mal avec le
terme surtoutisme actuellement sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est très difficile
d'utiliser ce mot-là mais je dirais
quand même le sur tourisme avec des pics
de fréquentation c'est quand même
quelque chose je trouve très intéressant
que les médias en parlent parce que ça
fait prendre conscience au touriste même
c'est-à-dire aux pratiquants qu'il y a
un problème mais c'est intéressant ce
débat autour du mot parce que est-ce que
on veut surtout pas se faire quand on a
un site touristique réputé se faire
accoler ce cet épithète là sur tourisme
de peur de de perdre le business on va
pardon je suis assez trivial mais c'est
un peu ça vous avez des destinations qui
elles-mêmes le font justement qui
commence à le faire c'est-à-dire qu'il
s'affiche en tant que dessination qui ne
souhaite pas avoir plus de touristes
donc c'est assez récent mais on le voit
mais dans les motivations des des
voyageurs c'est assez intéressant parce
que là on parlait de de finalement de la
prise de conscience environnementale qui
est réel est-ce que il y a un déc
sur l'environnement sur le patrimoine
on peut pas dire qu'à Gordon soit
vraiment touché par le tourisme de masse
encore une fois au sens de ce qui se
passe à Venise à dubrive ou dans
d'autres villes où là il y a réellement
une Athènes à la faune à la flore au
patrimoine à la culture et en dernier
analyse à la qualité de vie des
habitants qui sont les premiers à être
en quelque sorte dépossédés de même
pardon
c'est toujours compliqué quand l'inviter
n'est pas en plateau mais j'adore
j'adore le village de Gordes et ça m'est
arrivé plusieurs fois d'y aller en plein
été jour de marché bon il faut il faut
avoir vraiment envie de faire ses
courses dans le marché de Gordes ce
jour-là quoi tellement il y a de monde
donc si vous amène quand même si vous
allez dans de nombreux marchés
provençaux vous verrez effectivement
nous à Bordes c'est le mardi et c'est un
jour en juillet et août qui est très
difficile c'est certain le jour du
marché bon mais ça il n'empêche que
l'objectif c'est de réinjecter en fait
les financements du tourisme dans la
culture et le patrimoine ok on va qu'on
va on va continuer de détailler ça
ensemble notamment les investissements
que vous avez prévu pour on va dire
peut-être réguler un peu mieux ces
effets de du succès finalement
touristique ça pose aussi Florent Mayet
la question de la qualité du service moi
je le Mont Saint-Michel par exemple le
Mont-Saint-Michel de toute façon enfin
je vais sûrement faire beaucoup
d'ennemis là-bas mais ils ont besoin de
rien faire parce que les touristes ils
sont toujours là ils seront toujours là
donc la qualité
des jouets des fins de la nourriture etc
enfin on a vraiment l'impression que ils
ont pas besoin de faire des efforts
est-ce que vous vous faites ce lien je
pense que on va vivre un été une forme
de de passer au révélateur cet été au
niveau du panier moyen les Français font
des choix alors le choix reste de partir
effectivement parce que ça acte un peu
le fait qu'on est dans une société de
loisirs les gens partent en vacances les
gens en vacances vont payer plus cher
les dépenses contraintes l'hébergement
le transport ça c'est fait une fois que
vous serez sur place je vais pas prendre
de produits en particulier mais une
petite consommation vous offrir les
enfants qui coûtaient 3 euros avant 5
euros aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
là-dessus que les arbitrages vont se
faire quelque part fondamentalement je
séparais tout à l'heure les sites comme
la Tour Eiffel qui sont des sites
payants et les sites comme le Mont
Saint-Michel vous pouvez visiter
gratuitement vous n'êtes pas obligé de
consommer sur place et je pense que
c'est sur ce cet aspect là donc vous
dites professionnels attention peut-être
que cet été alors il va falloir
augmenter la qualité de service sinon
les Français qui sont à l'euro près
viendra les professionnels
malheureusement c'est compliqué parce
qu'ils soient eux-mêmes confrontés à un
manque de main d'oeuvre donc c'est
obligé de de ils ont moins de monde qui
doivent payer plus cher donc c'est déjà
compliqué pour eux et je pense que le
seuil de tolérance des gens sur cet
aspect là et largement dépassé
je voudrais donner quelques quelques
éléments sur les dégâts du sur tourisme
en terme environnementaux dans le monde
le secteur économique du tourisme c'est
responsable de 8% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre elle essaie de la France
on parle de 11% à des émissions du pays
puis alors il y a un autre un autre
chiffre un autre élément que moi j'ai
trouvé frappant que j'ai découvert en
préparant conditions aujourd'hui 52% des
déchets en mer Méditerranée sont issus
du tourisme balnéaire Sophie Lacourt
est-ce que sur cette question de des
effets je reprends l'expression des
effets délétères du tourisme sur des sur
des sites classés sur des sur des sur
des écosystèmes là on est au cœur de la
question là on est vraiment au cœur du
problème puisque le tourisme ramène de
l'attractivité économique sur les
territoires mais si ça détruit le
territoire sur lequel c'est en train de
se passer ça n'a pas de sens en fait
donc c'est tout à fait contre-productif
mais nous sommes dans des années
charnières par rapport au tourisme par
rapport au panier moyen mais beaucoup de
choses en fait le covid en fait a été
révélateur énormément de choses et c'est
extrêmement intéressant mais c'est très
difficile de tirer des grandes
conclusions sur le tourisme actuellement
parce qu'il y a des vrais changements
une véritable mutation à la fois des
clients et des professionnels il y a de
plus en plus de sites qui proposent
effectivement du tourisme durable du
tourisme responsable après qu'est-ce
permet derrière ces mots je suis assez
d'accord avec avec vous mais ça reste
encore minorée
[Musique]
ultra minoritaire par rapport aux 100%
du business touristique en France mais
toujours du temps et c'est la
responsabilité de tous les acteurs et de
et des consommateurs c'est vraiment ça
doit marcher la main dans la main et ce
que tu disais tout à l'heure est tout à
fait juste il y a une vraie on voit une
vraie dichotomie entre l'intention et la
réalité alors il y a un autre effet
effet sur l'immobilier et la capacité
des habitants à se loger c'est
évidemment très important écoutez ce
pêcheur Étretat
il y a un souci de touristes de tourisme
de masse
ce qui veut dire que maintenant pour se
loger ça devient compliqué pour se garer
ça devient compliqué pour vivre dans le
village ça devient compliqué donc le
tourisme de masse fait que il y a
beaucoup de Airbnb de gîtes etc donc les
touristes viennent aller 4 mois dans
l'année et ça occupé énormément de place
et du coup les écoles ferment les
commerces ferment et la vie locale en
disant il y a 350 personnes qui sont qui
sont parties habité à côté Richard
kittaff est-ce que vous vivez un
phénomène similaire à Gordes est-ce que
vous êtes par exemple obligé de réguler
les locations de vacances location
Airbnb et autres
alors depuis le début des années 70 et
le développement du tourisme à Gordes il
y a toujours eu ce problème que
malheureusement les locaux ne peuvent
pas s'installer se maintenir à Gordes
donc pour cela nous on a développe des
projets de résidence mixte
intergénérationnelles afin de permettre
aux jeunes familles de rester et chaque
année on se bat pour restaurer du
mobilier de l'immobilier communal et
donc introduire des nouvelles familles
dans la dans la commune donc c'est pour
ça qu'on n'a pas de fermeture de classe
effectivement je vous rejoins c'est une
stratégie à moyen terme qu'il faut mener
parce que tous les villages dans
lesquels et les villes dans lequel le
foncier s'envole sont des villages
menacés sur le plan de démographie qu'au
bout d'un certain temps pour répondre à
votre question plus directement sur la
réglementation il faut pas tout demander
au maire on a vraiment besoin de la
législation en fait étatique en dernière
analyse pour arriver à avoir les moyens
d'imposer réellement ce que nous voulons
en matière de meublé tourisme mais il
est clair que l'objectif c'est justement
de limiter ce phénomène des Airbnb il y
a des propositions actuellement
législatives qui vont en ce sens c'est
dès que nous pourrons nous les
appliquerons effectivement sur la
commune mais de manière raisonnée aussi
alors justement effectivement Laetitia
le gouvernement a planché alors plus
généralement sur cette question du du
sur tourisme c'était le 18 juin dernier
un plan dévoilé pour réguler les flux
touristiques mais elle a pas un plan sur
le surtorisme Thomas
plus touristique ce sont les mots
employés par Olivier agrégoire qui a
porté ce plan il vit à Grégoire ministre
du Tourisme l'artisanat du commerce
c'était lors d'un déplacement en
Bretagne et puis aussi elle avait fait
en parallèle une grande interview dans
le Figaro pour expliquer ce qu'il y aura
dans ce plan national et pourquoi pas de
surtourisme pourquoi pas ce mot parce
qu'il faut quand même surtout pas se
couper de cette manne financière qu'elle
tourisme et il faudrait pas non plus
écarter et puis bon finalement faire
fuir les touristes le principal c'est
qu'il reste là l'enjeu pour le
gouvernement c'est de les dévier de
dévier leur chemin c'est ça l'enjeu
principal les orienter sur des chemins
alternatifs mais pour ça il faut aider
les collectivités territoriales à
participer on va dire à l'élaboration de
ce plan c'est une évidence l'État ne
peut pas imposer aux collectivités un
plan sur le tourisme sans les faire
participer directement les départements
les régions et puis aussi les
municipalités et aussi bien sûr les
sites touristiques ça va commencer par
la mise en place d'un observatoire des
sites touristiques dont le gouvernement
va financer ça c'est important Thomas
parce que Olivier agrégoire a bien pris
soin de le répéter va financer des
outils de mesure il y aura en gros des
aides concrètes financières pour toutes
les collectivités territoriales à chaque
étape pourquoi parce que leur
collaboration est tout simplement
primordiale qu'il y aura aussi une phase
d'information du grand public oui alors
le gouvernement va un peu innover il l'a
déjà fait pendant le covid il va
demander aux influenceurs du tourisme il
va lancer une grande campagne de
communication sur les réseaux sociaux
pour bien sûr sensibiliser sur ces
questions du centurisme mais aussi je
vous disais tout à l'heure amener les
touristes sur d'autres chemins des
chemins alternatifs peut-être les
détourner du Mont-Saint-Michel pour
aller 20 km plus loin je ne sais pas ce
qu'il y a mais il y aura certainement
mais enfin bon courage et là aussi les
territoires sont associés oui les
territoires sont associés et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils vont mener des
grandes enquêtes avant de lancer ce plan
des grandes enquêtes chez les
populations locales pourquoi pour savoir
le seuil
d'acceptabilité du tourisme dans la
région on va aller sonder les habitants
locaux et on va aussi connaître les
raisons de leur rejet parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de rejets dans ces populations
locales donc vous l'avez vu les
territoires vont être associés par la
tête par les élus mais aussi par les
gens nous les gens évidemment alors tout
le monde veut réagir à ce plan annoncé
par par Olivia Grégoire je vous redonner
la parole Monsieur le Maire de Gordon
dans un instant peut-être Valérie bonnet
de votre avis pour pour commencer est-ce
qu'il est suffisamment ambitieux ce plan
dans une vraie volonté politique sur le
sujet globalement et ce sujet il est il
est d'ordre national fédératif on va
dire en effet il faut des grands axes
des moyens parce que il faut des moyens
même si on a la volonté il faut mettre
les moyens là on parle d'observatoire en
fait des études donc il faut et ça c'est
la première année voilà et ensuite pour
avoir un vrai plan d'action il faut
aussi être capable en même temps que
c'est national et fédératif il faut
aussi être capable d'être très proche
des territoires parce que ce qui est sûr
c'est que chaque territoire assez
particularités ses attentes donc et
l'autre point c'est qu'il faut mettre
autour de la table évidemment les
territoires évidemment l'état évidemment
les professionnels je veux dire les
hôteliers les restaurateurs
d'une certaine façon alors si comme j'ai
la parole juste je vais placer sur ça et
puis moi je représente les agences de
voyages et tout opérateur bon voilà
traditionnellement on passe par nous
pour partir on a l'impression que à
l'étranger mais c'est pas le cas
uniquement aussi la France même si elle
est moins intermédiaire mais on a un
rôle de conseils
on faisait notre séminaire à ce
moment-là donc on a déjeuné avec elle
mais oui mais il faut voilà pardon avec
Olivia Grégoire mais il faut absolument
mettre dans le tour de table des
intermédiaires nous on a une capacité à
orienter c'est ce qu'on fait déjà à
l'étranger et aussi en France mais on a
vraiment une capacité de prescripteur de
régulateur et on a une carte à jouer en
la matière et
c'est ce tour de table entièrement
collaboratif qui permettra d'avoir un
plan d'action nationale certes avec des
moyens et le décliner au niveau des
territoires
au moins déjà le mérite de pointer
pointer le phénomène d'une certaine
façon Grégoire ce qui pouvait paraître
surprenant c'est d'abord de cette espèce
de de coming out sur les chiffres c'est
à dire l'absence de chiffres finalement
c'est dire en fait on va étudier on est
la première destination touristique du
monde mais en fait on doit quand même
vous dire qu'on ne connaît pas nos
chiffres donc c'est quand même un petit
peu bizarre et si touristique pas
exactement exactement donc il y a cette
explication ce que vous me dites parce
que si si on n'a pas les chiffres
comment définir les zones où les pics de
fréquentation sont insupportables
mettent en péril
le les écosystèmes le patrimoine etc…
en associant professionnelle et
population donc sur ce plan là c'est
tout à fait cohérent ce qui est
compliqué pour lui donner un
retentissement c'est que finalement il
faut pas s'attendre à mesure très
spectaculaires il y aura pas
d'interdiction de partir pendant les
vacances le président a vaguement tenté
de parler des calendriers des vacances
scolaires on a vu on a vu la on a vu la
réaction et qu'il y aura pas d'annonce
spectaculaire il y aura des petites
jauges tiens de masse que vous savez que
demain commence une jauge sur l'île de
Bréhat j'ai entendu ça le confrères de
France Info ce jeudi matin intéressant
c'est qu'on constate il n'y a pas de
retour en arrière c'est à dire les
destinations je pense aux calanques de
sugit ton je pense à Porquerolles il n'y
a pas de retour en arrière une fois
qu'on a fixé ses jauge elles sont
vraisemblablement plutôt bien acceptées
ça tombe bien on va y répondre dans un
instant je donne la parole au maire de
Gorica qui t'arrive sur ce plan
gouvernemental vous lit intervenir
oui je crois que le plan de
gouvernemental est une très bonne chose
mais encore faut-il qu'il puisse aller
jusqu'au bout parce que lorsqu'on parle
du consensus et le fédératif il faut
aussi se demander si l'échelon
international est pris en compte puisque
si on considère que le tourisme de masse
est quand même un des effets majeurs de
la mondialisation économique on peut se
demander si l'absence de prise en compte
de du niveau international ne créera pas
des problèmes il y a des territoires par
exemple l'île de Pâques dans lesquelles
la liberté d'aller venir a été limitée
pour ne plus continuer à détruire
certaines territoires qui subissaient un
tourisme massif donc je pense que si on
introduit pas un moment donné cette
question des comptages et des jauges à
un niveau international et seulement
pour le cas extrême des destinations
touchées par le vrai tourisme de masse
ça risque d'être beaucoup de réflexion
pour pas grand chose d'opérationnel
si on est très concret vous annoncez je
crois 3 millions de d'euros
d'investissement pour réguler le
tourisme dans votre ville pour quel type
d'infrastructure ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire 3 millions d'euros
d'investissement dans l’hypercentre du
village qui subit le plus les pics de
fréquentation touristique ça veut dire
créer des places et des placettes de
convivialité qui n'existent pas
actuellement pour la qualité de vie des
habitants à l'année ça veut dire
diminuer l'impact de l'automobile
réorganiser et rationaliser les flux de
circulation et de piétonnisation pour
supprimer en fait cet effet de de
tourisme rapide et c'est aussi le fait
de valoriser l'esthétique changer les
mobiliers urbains et valoriser le
patrimoine donc c'est un exemple qu'on
essaye de rendre positif de réinjecter
l'argent du tourisme pour améliorer la
qualité du territoire
effectivement donc là on est dans le
concret on va vous avez évoqué la
question des cottages je vous propose de
détailler ce thème avec d'abord un
extrait d'artage qu'on a déjà diffusé
sur la chaîne sur public Sénart ou
portage signé Samia de Chiron on est aux
îles Lavezzi en Corse avec un défenseur
de l'environnement et de son île
cela fait plus de 30 ans que Jean-Michel
goulioli travaille à la préservation de
l'île Lavezzi un petit bout de terre de
69 hectares ou certaines espèces
d'oiseaux protégées viennent se
reproduire et il sait exactement où
trouver leur nid le plus niche en
dessous c'est un sa famille de Albatros
c'est la plus grande colonie de
Méditerranée neur-occidentale ils
viennent se reproduire sous ses rochers
ils ont besoin de tranquillité pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir assurer la la
couvaison et puis après l'élevage des
jeunes abrite aussi des plantes uniques
comme le limonium lambidonie les
sentiers ne suffisent pas toujours à la
protéger du piétinement il faut qu'on
puisse avoir un petit sentier qui soit
juste qu'il soit juste à côté et encore
une fois sur ce petit sentier on peut
pas mettre 300 personnes en même temps à
côté donc il faut qu'on ait un moment
donné une véritable réflexion sur la
canalisation mais aussi sur la
quantification et donc sur la notion de
totale alors cette notion de quota de
réservation n'en parle tout de suite
avec vous tam-tranu et comme promis on
part on part dans les calanques mais oui
quand je vous dis calanque vous pensez
paysage splendide vierge crique émeraude
et surtout déserte vous pensez faune et
flore à perte de vue et vous ne pensez
pas recherche désespérée d'espace pour
poser votre serviette entre deux voisins
bruyants mais malheureusement dès les
beaux jours c'est ce que vous risquez de
voir parce que les calanques
effectivement sont prises d'assaut
certaines plages accueillent l'été entre
1000 3000 personnes avec un impact
majeur sur ces sites érosion des sols
piétinement de la pinède problème de
déchets etc ce problème il ne date pas
d'hier déjà en 2008 la surfécantation du
site était l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles certains défendaient le
classement des Calanques en parc
national regardez
actuellement un million 300 000
visiteurs par an dans les calanques
c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à maîtriser
parce qu'on le maîtrise plus en ce
moment c'est c'est la folie Sormiou il y
a 1000 voitures le dimanche
morjou c'est pareil les goûts ils
mettent trois heures pour sortir des
gouttes donc il faut maîtriser ce flux
et un parc national arrivera à le
maîtriser voilà ça date bien de 2008 et
finalement et bien les calanques de
Marseille Cassis La Ciotat etc ont
finalement été classés parc national en
2012 mais cela n'a pas suffi puisque
aujourd'hui elles attirent environ 3
millions de visiteurs par an ce qui a
été mis en place pour limiter la
fréquentation d'abord il y a eu le des
marketing c'est de l'anticommunication
pour décourager les visiteurs de venir
regardez sur quoi on tombe quand on
clique sur la rubrique plage et baignade
du site internet des Calanques on tombe
sur ça massif montagneux en bord de mer
les calanques offrent peu de plages
situés au creux des criques dénué
d'équipement elles sont souvent
difficiles d'accès exigu et prise
d'assaut pendant la période festival
tout ça vous le voyez accompagné de
photos de plages bondées objectifs
maîtriser l'attrait du territoire voilà
on dit sa poliment pour dire vraiment
vous dégoûtez d'avance car à l'été 2020
il y a un pic inquiétant qui a été
atteint 3000 visiteurs par jour soit 2,3
personnes au mètre carré dans certaines
calanques 240 bateaux comptés en une
heure au Cap Croisette le 15 août il
faut dire que le covid n'avait pas aidé
s'il a été synonyme de calanque déserte
pendant le confinement et là aussi
signifié vacances en France pour
beaucoup de personnes mais au-delà de ce
phénomène exceptionnel on sait bien que
la tendance à l'augmentation est bien là
et donc on accède plus aux calanques
comme ça et oui certaines calanques
comme celle de Sugiton et celle de la
pierre tombée sont désormais accessibles
sur réservation gratuite pendant l'été
réserver ses préserver tel est le slogan
aujourd'hui pour limiter le nombre de
visiteurs à 400 par jour au lieu de 2500
les pires journée des quotas de bateaux
à moteur sont aussi imposés depuis 2020
pour préserver le milieu marin et la
réflexion est en cours pour mettre en
place le même système de réservation
pour les îles du Frioul qui appartient
au Parc national des Calanques et c'est
un système vous l'avez dit qu'il fait
des émules un peu partout en France
puisque l'île de Bréhat dans les
Côtes-d'Armor se garde la possibilité de
réguler l'accès la circulation des
personnes cet été comment donc des
expérimentations c'est donc fini la
Bretagne ça vous gagne nouveau slogan
ici c'est tout pourri
terminer votre dernière chronique de la
semaine on part ici c'est tout pourri je
me spécialise en démarquer
c'était pas mal pour quelqu'un qui a
fêté la fin de saison hier soir
franchement deux très très bonnes
chroniques merci beaucoup tu as traduit
effectivement c'est passionnant quand
même ce thème du des quotas et ça
rejoint une autre question qui est la
question de de la sélection par l'argent
qui est une question centrale et il faut
prendre un peu de temps pour pour en
discuter tous ensemble je commence avec
vous Valérie bonnet est-ce que c'est
finalement le risque
un moment où on va dire oh bah il y a
trop de monde sur ces sites donc faisons
faisons payer cher l'accès et la
question sera réglée c'est clair que ça
pose quand même une vraie question dans
une société dans laquelle on a un accès
aux vacances et un droit aux vacances
entre guillemets il faut rappeler qu'il
y a 40 % des Français qui partent pas en
vacances et cette année 13% de ses 40%
partez l'année dernière d'accord donc il
y a quand même quelque chose avec
l'inflation et le coup
oui l'accès la sélection par l'argent il
y a quelque chose de choquant enfin en
tout cas c'est ça rejoint aussi le fait
de voyager en avion est-ce que ça va
devenir très cher ou pas etc
il faut absolument garder en équilibre
dans les choses il y a effectivement des
sites qui sont payants mais moi j'ai
envie de vous dire il y a des sites
aussi sur lesquels on ne va pas le
week-end on ne va pas la nuit on ne va
pas le soir il y a toute une mentalité à
changer alors là on va toucher au droit
du travail etc mais on parle du Louvre
on parle des musées fermés le mardi en
général etc il y a quand même des
potentiels de d'étirements dans le temps
pourquoi ne pas ouvrir des sites qui
sont fermés à des moments dans le temps
et le faire pour donner accès plus
facilement de façon plus fluide à des
gens et non pas forcément alors bien sûr
qu'on va on va peut-être rendre plus
cher des sites déjà accessibles en
payant mais il y a d'autres voix aussi
et je pense que ça relève de d'une vraie
volonté là encore politique de d'ouvrir
le champ des possibles Sophie Latour
est-ce que c'est déjà en train de se
passer c'est à dire la régulation par
l'argent sur certains sites
sur ça il est bien évident qu'il ne faut
pas que ça se produise le drone va
commencer pour tous en fait et ce serait
la fin du tourisme pour tous par contre
l'étalement de l'exploitation des sites
à d'autres horaires ça oui ça fait déjà
longtemps qu'on en parle parce que le
Louvre en fait c'est un vieux problème
le Louvre quand même c'est très
fréquenté depuis des dizaines d'années
et donc ouvrir des sites la nuit les
autres jours presque 24 heures sur 24 en
fait les infrastructures sont là
utilisons-les justement alors pour être
une solution pour des édifices des
musées ok mais pour les plages sur les
plages du sud les plus enfin les places
de France les plus demandées comment on
fait difficile mais là pareil alors
justement on reparle les calanques moi
j'ai énormément aimé le travail qu'ils
ont fait dessus parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que ils ont effectivement
interdit et réguler on va dire plutôt
réguler qu'interdit le nombre de
personnes qui ont accès mais il y a
aussi des agents qui sont là tout le
temps des vacances pour donner d'autres
adresses d'autres lieux le pas de côté
allez justement
pas cette plage là mais essayez d'aller
un petit peu plus loin sur un autre
endroit et ça c'est très intéressant
régulation des flux en fait c'est l'un
des grands secrets du tourisme vous
parliez Florent effectivement qui qui
met en place là aussi un système de
quota on peut dire ça comme ça avec un
nombre de
visiteurs limité par bateau et par jour
etc moi j'entendais dans un portage
radio ce matin une des épicières du de
l'île dire bah oui mais attention à moi
mon chiffre je le fais pendant l'été et
j'ai un loyer très important et je vais
pas tenir ma boutique l'hiver si je fais
pas le même chiffre pendant l'été c'est
un vrai argument qu'on peut entendre
c'est un vrai argument ce que ça
souligne surtout c'est le manque de de
planification finalement parce que on
parlait de l'argent c'est un vrai faux
problème aujourd'hui vous avez accès à
des plages mais vous avez à côté un
parking que vous payez extrêmement cher
la question c'est finalement une fois
que vous récoltez cet argent où est-ce
que vous en affectez le produit si vous
en affectez le produit on peut remonter
loin dans le temps et rappelons-nous des
classes de neige à l'époque le
gouvernement il avait lancé en neige en
disant on veut que les Français
profitent de la montagne etc ils
subventionné les sorties des écoliers
pour aller découvrir les joies de la
neige les entreprises et les comités
d'entreprises permettaient aux gens de
partir en vacances à la neige sont quand
même des des vacances relativement
onéreuses donc c'est plus un problème
d'organisation globale que de prix ou de
dire sur l'île de Bréal à la voilà la
boulangère peut-être que si elle a
l'assurance que sur 6 mois alors un
chiffre d'affaires plutôt que sur deux
mois l'envisagera les choses
différemment l'acceptabilité mais dans
le même reportage Thomas il faut être
juste il y en avait une autre habitante
qui disait mais j'en peux plus je
reconnais pas bien sûr
volontairement parce que c'est l'impact
économique de la régulation du du
Tourisme on est dans cette équation
compliquée je pense alors on en a pas
encore parlé mais il y a aussi la prise
de conscience
du visiteurs enfin la responsabilité du
consommateur du visiteur du voyageur et
là quand même alors il y a une prise de
conscience un peu mais on peut aussi
attendre des personnes qui sont
concernées qu'elles prennent un peu de
recul dans les chiffres de cet été ce
que l'on voit quand même et c'est assez
récent c'est qu'on a plus 8 % de
voyageurs on parle des vacances
scolaires de l'été en juillet par
rapport à l'année dernière plus 18% en
septembre et le pic qu'on avait en août
de très grandes fréquentations de très
grands départs qui s’érodent en fait un
petit peu ça veut dire l'inflation
c'est-à-dire que la première semaine si
j'ai bien compris de juillet et la
dernière semaine
traditionnellement mais quand même mais
quand même ça c'est c'est pas nouveau
tellement
il y a une prise de conscience et il
faut aussi miser quand on parle des
parties prenantes il y a aussi la
conscience de ceux qui voyagent toujours
sur cette question de régulation par
l'argent Richard kitaeff vous parliez de
votre volonté peut-être de réduire la
place de la voiture dans dans le cœur de
de Gordes est-ce que ça passe par le
prix des parkings par exemple
ça passe par le prix du parking mais je
refuse de parler de régulation par
l'argent dans le sens où ça c'est le
rôle des c'est le rôle et la mission des
opérateurs privés pas de la puissance
publique par exemple le la segmentation
de l'offre touristique c'est une forme
de sélection dans la mesure où vous
choisissez d'aller soit un camping soit
un palace et à Gordes on a par exemple
l'un des 31 Palace mais on a aussi un
camping et des snacks etc donc il y a
toutes sortes d'offres touristiques par
contre le rôle de la puissance publique
effectivement c'est de laisser le
territoire vivant pour ses habitants et
d'utiliser l'argent du tourisme pour le
réinjecter dans le patrimoine et la
culture donc pour vous répondre oui
cette année nous avons augmenté le tarif
des parkings mais c'est une forme de
droit d'entrée d'autorisation d'accéder
à un village qui est aujourd'hui côté au
niveau mondial en quelque sorte je le
dis sans fausse modestie c'est voilà
c'est juste pour exprimer le fait qu'à
partir du moment où vous avez près d'un
million de visiteurs et où votre
objectif ce n'est pas d'augmenter les
parkings pour garder des espaces
naturels et écologiques forcément mais
vous devez augmenter le prix des
parkings parce que si les parkings sont
gratuits vous avez 100 fois plus de
monde voilà mais c'est plus un droit
d'entrée que nous réinjectons ensuite
dans le patrimoine c'est allez on va
terminer sur la question enfin qui est
au centre du débat de la démocratisation
de du voyage finalement est-ce que on va
assister à un retournement il y a ce que
l'ingénieur professeur à l'École des
Mines Jean Marc Jancovici dit à propos
de l'avion vous l'avez tous entendu ce
chiffre pour tenir l'objectif du mot des
températures de 2 degrés par rapport à
l'air pré-industriel il faudrait se
limiter à quatre vols seulement dans une
vie comment vous avez réagi en entendant
ça voilà bon évidemment nous on est
prescripteur de transport et notamment
en avion parce qu'on envoie les joints
enfin on répond à la demande des
Français qui veulent voyager à
l'étranger
cette déclaration elle est elle est
certainement sincère mais elle est aussi
très voilà elle est là pour faire réagir
alors je veux pas
encore une fois j'ai envie de dire il
faut de la nuance partout et de
l'équilibre partout il y a la façon dont
effectivement les motif de voyager mais
quand je quand vous parlez comme quand
on entend ça les gens qui se déplacent
pour retourner dans leur famille par
exemple nous on a des liens dans les
drones etc enfin ce sont des choses
absolument déconnectées de la réalité en
revanche qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
voyager en émettant moins de carbone en
avion ça ce sont des sujets alors c'est
en plus d'actualité mais il y a des
pistes qui n'ont pas été encore assez
voilà exploiter il y a des enjeux et
puis il y a la compensation au bout du
bout quand on a fait tous les efforts
des compensation ou de l'absorption et
puis on peut considérer ce fil à tout la
cour que enfin c'est super égoïste de la
part de notre génération on a vécu la
démocratisation du voyage à profiter on
a pris l'avion sans se poser de
questions et nos enfants ou nos petits
enfants pourront pas quoi c'est un vrai
problème mais là je peux pas porter de
réponse à ça c'est beaucoup trop
compliqué en fait comme réponse là je il
y a quand sur l'équation que nous
propose le secteur aérien qui nous dit
on est à 5 milliards de de voyageurs
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est c'est
toujours de doubler de passer à 10
milliards sauf qu'on n'a pas la
technologie pour faire l'avion propre
donc moi je vois pas le genre ça marche
pas l'avion et pour le tourisme tout le
monde ne prend pas l'avion pour faire du
tourisme donc il y a aussi beaucoup
d'alternatives à explorer et justement
du tourisme sans avion ça existe aussi
bon allez on termine là-dessus merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce à ce débat je vous souhaite un bel
été je voudrais remercier le public de
sens public de sa fidélité parce qu'on
va des records d'audience vous êtes
400000 à nous suivre tous les soirs donc
ça nous fait évidemment plaisir je
remercie Perrine Tarnaud la directrice
de l'information de Public Sénat merci à
Elsa Dario la haute Fauvel Alice
Bordeaux et Pénélope qui s'adapte qui
forme la dream team de sens public c'est
un bonheur de bosser avec vous et on se
retrouve à la rentrée merci à toutes les
équipes éditoriales et techniques de
Public Sénat Laetitia c'était aussi un
grand bonheur de vous retrouver sur ce
plateau
voilà après une petite pause et vous
serez là évidemment à la rentrée le 4
septembre je vous donne rendez-vous avec
une belle surprise pour cette rentrée et
d'ici là jusqu'à la fin juillet on est
là tous les jours avec les meilleurs
débats de sens public salut et ça y est
c'est les vacances c'est l'été